this is what happens when you work to
change things and first they think
you're crazy then they fight you
Elizabeth Holmes promises
laboratory tests from a tiny sample or a
few drops of blood I don't have many
Secrets um
[Music]
on November 18th 2022 Elizabeth Holmes
is scheduled to be sentenced for wanting
one of the biggest frauds on Silicon
Valley if you're not familiar with
Elizabeth she was the founder of an
ambitious biotech company called
theranos the company promised to
revolutionize a blood test by reducing
blood samples to a single drop of blood
as someone who's not the biggest fan of
needles this sounds like an awesome idea
and it appears that millions of
consumers and investors agreed at the
peak theranos had raised an impressive
724 million dollars from VCS and several
notable investors this included the
likes of Larry Ellison the Walton family
Rupert Murdoch Carlos Lim and Robert
Kraft from their perspective theranos
was probably a no-brainer investment the
goal of the company was easy to grasp
and it had extremely intelligent people
behind it like Elizabeth herself
Elizabeth was a Stanford chemical
engineering Dropout I mean this is the
exact recipe for Silicon Valley success
stories but their nose was anything but
a success story while theranos would
reach evaluation of up to 10 billion
dollars it turned out that their nose
was just one big house of cards held
together with lies and deception and
that brings us to where we are today
Elizabeth and her business partner
Ramesh Sunni balwani are each facing up
to 20 years in prison and a fine of 250
000 plus restitution for each kind of
conspiracy and wire fraud so here's
exactly how silicon Valley's biggest
fraud was exposed and the disastrous
consequences that followed
foreign
taking a look back the story of
theranos's downfall dates back to early
2015. at the time the company had
already been around for 12 years but
this doesn't mean that Elizabeth was
able to keep up their thought for
anywhere near that long you see it there
are no said maintained a virtually
non-existent Public Image up until 2013.
so for the longest time Elizabeth did
not need to convince the public of
anything she just needed to convince a
few dozen investors now it's not easy to
convince investors but more times than
not their primary objections relate to
the financial success of the company as
opposed to the legitimacy of the company
itself and when it came to finances this
company was a grand slam if they truly
did achieve what they were promising the
company would probably be worth hundreds
of billions today combine this with
several heavyweight players on both the
company side and the investor side not
to mention dozens of patents and it's
unlikely that any investor consider the
possibility of fraud all that much but
while Elizabeth was able to pull a quick
one on investors her facade did not hold
up all that well in the face of public
scrutiny their nose couldn't put off a
public reveal forever though so in
September of 2013 they made their first
public move by partnering with Walgreens
the deal entailed slowly rolling out
therano's testing centers across
Walgreens Nationwide while consumers had
yet to really hear about this company
until now it didn't take long for many
of them to be convinced thanks to
Elizabeth's marketing efforts she would
appear on the covers of Fortune Forbes
the New York Times style magazine and
Inc Forbes also labeled her as the
youngest self-made billionaire in the
world and ranked turret at the 110th
richest American but their known as
marketing wasn't the only thing that was
on point their pricing was also on point
naturally you would expect that such a
revolutionary product would cost an arm
and a leg but it was actually relatively
affordable and was largely covered by
many notable insurance companies such as
capital Blue Cross and amerihealth
decaritus all of this resulted in 175
000 people buying 7.8 million test
results from theranos but while
Elizabeth had a general public investors
and partners completely duped the same
could it not be said about medical
experts while they were massive
proponents of such advancements
themselves they couldn't help but feel
that theranos was pushing the balance of
what was relatively possible with
current technology one such skeptic was
a missouri-based pathologist who took
their concerns to an investigative
journalist named John Kerry at their
Wall Street your Journal as you would
guess John had no idea what he was about
to discover but as a good journalist he
followed this lead and started
investigating the journals he would
eventually get in contact with the
former lab director of theranos Adam
rosendorf who would spill the beans on
their nose over the next several months
John would continue his investigation
and secure whistleblowers including
Erica Chung and the telephones despite
Jon's efforts to keep the investigation
discreet though theranos would
eventually hear about it Elizabeth would
go to Rupert Murdoch who actually owns
The Wall Street Journal and asked him to
cancel the story but this pressure to
cancel the story just convinced Johnny
even more that he needed to publish it
and that's exactly what he would do
foreign
October 16 2015 The Wall Street Journal
would post an article titled hot startup
theranos has struggled with its blood
test technology Silicon Valley lab led
by Elizabeth Holmes is valued at 9
billion dollars but isn't using its
technology for all the tests it offers
the article revealed how theranos was
only using their quote-unquote
proprietary technology for a small
fraction of their exams this in itself
did it not have to be a problem per se
if they were upfront about how the
technology only works for a small subset
of exams and that they were still
working on expanding its scope I think
that would have been completely
understandable but instead it they
decided to keep up the facade that their
technology accomplished more than it
really did they continued to collect
small blood samples even for tests that
they couldn't complete and they would
simply dilute these samples and run them
through traditional Machinery as you
would guess this often resulted in
heavily skewed results to make things
worse their proprietary technology
wasn't all that reliable in the first
place so they really hadn't accomplished
much of anything nonetheless after this
report was published Elizabeth would
aggressively deny all allegations and
threatened to sue John for defamation
but while Elizabeth was able to get away
with lying to investors and the public
she couldn't get away with lying to the
FDA the FDA would conduct their own
investigation which proved the accuracy
of Jon's entire report and at this point
it was all but over for theranos and it
was just a matter of waiting for the
house of cards to topple over in January
of 2016 the centers for Medicare and the
Medicaid services or CMS would send a
warning letter to theranos instructing
them to fix the irregularities across
their testing within just two months
this polite warning turned into a threat
the CMS proposed Banning Elizabeth from
the laboratory industry for two years
and just three months later this
proposal would it turn into action
Elizabeth would of course try appealing
this decision but that that didn't get
her anywhere in the meantime Walgreens
would end their relationship with
theranos and close all of their in-store
blood collection centers the FDA would
also ban the USF teranosis Infamous
nanotanerus which essentially wiped out
theranos's entire business they added no
product left to sell and no one willing
to sell it so darrenos had no option but
to start laying off all their employees
at their peak in late 2015 they had a
total of 800 employees but by April of
2018 they had less than two dozen
employees and most of these employees
would be laid off by August as well at
this point it was clear that even if
theranos didn't figure out blood tests
with the micro samples the company's
reputation was so bad that they could
simply never recover so with no choice
left on September 4th 2018 theranos
announced that they were going to
dissolve
foreign
has been shut down for years now the
repercussions of their actions are still
very much present with multiple lawsuits
ongoing one of the first entities to
take action against theranos was the
state of Arizona in 2017. they alleged
that the company had sold a 1.5
misleading blood tests in the state and
the theranos would end up settling for
4.65 million dollars Arizona wasn't the
only one that was suing theranos either
shareholders were of course also livid
and wanted to recoup as much as possible
but a judge would actually rule that
investors were not eligible to pursue a
class action lawsuit against their
owners you see it Securities laws are
intended to protect retail investors
from public companies but theranos
wasn't a public company and its
investors weren't retail so this made
the investors ineligible to sue under
Federal Securities laws the investors
tried getting around this by suing out
under California state laws but the
judge struck this down as well with
their legal options exhausted MO most
Journal shoulders would adjust right off
the investment at the loss and to move
on or settle for pennies on the dollar
Rupert Murdoch for example invested 125
million dollars into their owners and it
ended up selling back his shares for
just one dollar he did receive 4 million
when the other shareholders came to a
settlement with fairness but he still
lost 121 million dollars or 97 and this
has been the same case with most
investors except Elizabeth herself who
has actually been living it up after
being pushed out of their nose Elizabeth
turned around and started dating Billy
Evans who was the heir to the Evans
Hotel Group they have since gotten
married and even have a kid together
they currently live in 135 million
estate in Silicon Valley if you just saw
her lifestyle today you would think that
terranos was a massive success but the
most drippy part is that one of her
neighbors is Larry Ellison imagine being
scammed for tens of millions if not
hundreds of millions and then the
scammer moves in next door fortunate
Nelly Larry owns two dozen properties in
Malibu alone so he can stay far away
from Elizabeth but I'd be surprised if
this didn't bother him at least a little
anyway while Elizabeth has been able to
escape investor accountability for the
most part the same cannot be said about
the criminal lawsuits against her in
June of 2018 the doj charged Elizabeth
and her Co with 11 counts of criminal
felony and at the beginning of 2022 she
was convicted on three charges of wire
fraud and one count of conspiracy to
commit wire fraud and that brings us to
where we are today Elizabeth is
currently free on a 500 000 Bond and is
waiting for sentencing the scheduled for
November 18 2022 while she faces up to
20 years in prison most experts doubt
them she'll actually serve anywhere near
that amount however it's also unlikely
that she'll be able to get away within
no prison time the most likely scenario
is that she ends up serving less than 10
years at a low security prison
foreign
Holmes has become infamous as one of the
largest fraudsters in Silicon Valley she
didn't actually do anything that out of
the box she was really just trying to
fake it till she made it which is
extremely common in Silicon Valley if
she had more time and money it's
possible that she would have actually
developed the technology for real and
even if the truth about the early days
did Surface after that it probably
wouldn't have done anything it probably
would have just resulted in some sort of
finite but theranos would still be up
and running this is probably what
Elizabeth was hoping for but
unfortunately she tried the strategy in
the wrong industry if you try this
strategy in the tech industry she
probably could have gotten away with it
but the reason this works in the tech
industry is because the consequences of
not delivering it aren't that
significant worst case scenario you take
a reputational hit with clients and
might get sued but in the medical
industry Elizabeth was literally playing
with lives doctors were making
life-changing medical recommendations
based on tests results from their nose
and the consequence of this can never
truly be measured and this alone makes
Elizabeth's actions criminal and
inexcusable but that's just what I think
what do you think Elizabeth's punishment
should be comment that down below also
drop a like if you wish someone had
actually developed this for real
and of course consider checking out our
Discord Community to suggest future
video ideas and then consider
subscribing to see more questions
logically answered until then I'm Hari
and I'll see you guys on the next one